imagine we are living in prehistoric
times
now consider the following
how did we keep track of time without a
clock
all clocks are based on some repetitive
pattern which divides the flow of time
into equal segments
to find these repetitive patterns we
look towards the heavens
the sun rising and falling each day is
the most obvious however to keep track
of longer periods of time we looked for
longer cycles for this we looked to the
moon which seemed to gradually grow and
shrink over many days
when we count the number of days between
full moons we arrive at the number 29
this is the origin of a month however if
we try to divide 29 into equal pieces we
run into a problem it is impossible
the only way to divide 29 into equal
pieces is to break it back down into
single units 29 is a prime number think
of it as unbreakable
if a number can be broken down into
equal pieces greater than one we call it
a composite number now if we are curious
we may wonder how many prime numbers are
there and how big do they get
let's start by dividing all numbers into
two categories we list the primes on the
left and the composites on the right
at first they seem to dance back and
forth there is no obvious pattern here
so let's use a modern technique to see
the big picture the trick is to use a
ulum spiral
first we list all possible numbers in
order in a growing spiral
then we color all the prime numbers blue
finally we zoom out to see millions of
numbers
this is the pattern of primes which goes
on and on forever incredibly the entire
structure of this pattern is still
unsolved today
we are on to something so let's fast
forward to around 300 bc in ancient
greece a philosopher known as euclid of
alexandria understood that all numbers
could be split into these two distinct
categories he began by realizing that
any number can be divided down over and
over until you reach a group of smallest
equal numbers
and by definition these smallest numbers
are always prime numbers
so he knew that all numbers are somehow
built out of smaller primes
to be clear imagine the universe of all
numbers and ignore the primes
now pick any composite number and break
it down
and you are always left with prime
numbers so euclid knew that every number
could be expressed using a group of
smaller primes think of these as
building blocks no matter what number
you choose it can always be built with
an addition of smaller primes this is
the root of his discovery known as the
fundamental theorem of arithmetic
as follows
take any number say 30 and find all the
prime numbers it divides into equally
this we know as factorization
this will give us the prime factors in
this case 2 3 and 5 are the prime
factors of 30.
you could realize that you could then
multiply these prime factors a specific
number of times to build the original
number in this case you simply multiply
each factor once to build 30 2 times 3
times 5 is the prime factorization of
30. think of it as a special key or
combination there is no other way to
build 30 using some other groups of
prime numbers multiplied together
so every possible number has one and
only one prime factorization a good
analogy is to imagine each number as a
different lock the unique key for each
lock would be its prime factorization no
two locks share a key
no two numbers share a prime
factorization